hey guys we see here with a quick
gamespot news update for you are you fed
up of those horrendously long bloodborne
loading screens well good news because
it is patch o clock a new update to the
PlayStation 4 exclusive has
significantly reduced loading times with
the weight between deaths now cut by up
to 15 seconds previously waiting times
in areas such as central yarn and
laughter between 40 to 45 seconds 45
seconds of seeing the name of the game
on a black screen exciting guff from
software the tokyo-based studio
responsible for the game announced in
march that it was exploring
possibilities to expedite wait times the
1.03 update which has begun to roll out
across North America Japan and Europe
weighs in at 2.7 gigabytes and brings a
number of other improvements and tweaks
among the new changes is the
implementation of text pages displayed
during loading screens whereas before
loading tweens with just the basic image
of the bloodborne logo now they cycle
through various descriptions of items
that players encounter throughout the
game the patch also includes a number of
bug fixes including fixing inoperable
elevators immobilized bosses and
matchmaking issues related to the
playstation cause new suspend receive
beecher maybe those reduced loading
screens will make dying just a little
bit more bearable well probably not
anyway are there any other fixes you'd
like to see let me know in the comment
section below and for your blood related
gaming needs make sure you keep your eye
on gamespot
you